SPEAKER 1: Android Oreo is here
and available to consumers.
Hopefully, you've
taken the opportunity
to test and update your apps
during the long preview process
so those influential,
vocal early adopters have
a great experience.
Let's review what O brings-
a chocolate sandwich cookie
of important structural changes
with sweet new capabilities.
The most important stuff first.
You should keep in mind that
even if your app doesn't yet
target O, it will behave
differently on O in a few ways.
When your app is in
the background, i.e.
without an active activity
or foreground service,
location updates will be
significantly less frequent.
When your app no longer has
an active activity, service,
or other component
any wake locks at hold
will be automatically released.
For devices that come
with Google Play services,
settings not secured
on Android ID
will return a different
value for each app
based upon the sign-in
key and user profile.
For advertising, you
really need to be
using Google Play services
user-resettable advertising ID.
Here's another
privacy-related change.
Apps targeting O won't
be able to get access
to user accounts using the
get accounts permission.
Instead, apps must rely on
the account user activity.
Account owners can now choose
whether their accounts will
be visible to other apps and
the account user activity
will be updated accordingly.
If you're targeting O, your
app will have new limits
on background processing.
In summary, only a small
number of broadcast
can be used to start your
app, such as Boot Completed.
Also, your app will no longer
be able to start services
when in the background.
You'll need to rely on explicit
broadcast receivers, Jobs,
Firebase Cloud Messaging, and
startForeground, a new API
to start foreground services.
Android Oreo adds features to
support wide gamut displays,
including 16-bit PNG
and ICC profiles,
JPEG, PNG, and WebP,
along with new utilities
such as color space
and color log.
Android O also supports a
longer, narrower screens,
and apps that target
Android O no longer
have a default maximum
aspect ratio of 1.86.
If your activity needs to
set a maximum aspect ratio,
the system will
letterbox your app
if you set resizeable
activity to false
and use the max aspect
ratio attribute.
Of course, it's best to make
your app work fullscreen
and with multi-window, so only
use this as a last resort.
To make it easier to correct
graphics driver issues,
Android O device
manufacturers may
choose to update these
drivers in the Play Store
without having to
do a system update.
And of course, Android O is
built on Project Treble, so
devices that ship
with O will be easier
to update to new versions
of Android in future.
Android Oreo gives
users fine-grain control
over notifications by adding
notification channels.
Apps can declare channels, which
show up to users as categories.
Users can block a category and
alter its behavior controlling
vibration, lights, and
lock screen privacy.
Apps can target Android
O must use channels
if they use notifications.
We call the notification manager
to create notification channels
and then we set the
notification channel ID
in the compact
notification builder.
Android O also supports
notification badging and dots
by default in a channel.
We can turn this off by setting
set show badge to false.
Android Oreo now allows apps to
request adding their AppWidget
to the launcher.
You can easily check to see if
AppWidget pinning requests are
supported by the
default launcher
and then have your app
request them in your UI.
And we've changed the way
adding shortcuts works,
eliminating the broadcast
used in Android 7.1.
Similar to AppWidgets,
you can check
to see if shortcut pinning
requests are supported
and then have your
app request them.
Picture in Picture is now
available for all devices, not
just Android TV.
To specify if your
activity can use PiP mode,
set Android [INAUDIBLE]
supports Picture in Picture
to true in the manifest.
All an app has to do to
start Picture in Picture
is call enter Picture
in Picture mode
from a resumed or pause state.
Activities can now be
launched by the app
on secondary displays using
activity options, simpler
and easier than the
presentation API.
In addition, activities
that support multi-window
can be launched by a user
on secondary displays.
These displays have per
display based configurations
and resource management.
This means that some parts
of the configuration,
such as screen width DP, screen
high DP, layout, and density DP
will be set according to display
on which the activity currently
resides.
Fonts now are a fully-supported
resource type in Android O
and have also been
back-ported to API 14
in the support library.
You can use the get font
method to get a font by ID
and use these fonts
directly in text views.
You can also define entire
font families in XML,
declaring the font
styles and weights,
along with the font resource.
Downloadable fonts are
also supported in O
and implemented in
the support library.
These fonts are shared
between applications,
making better use of storage.
The 800 plus Google Fonts
are now available directly
within Android
Studio, where they
can either be
embedded in your ABK
or set to download on-demand.
One of my favorite Android Oreo
and support library features
is TextView AutoSizing.
You can create an array
of preset text sizes
or set min and max sizes
with a step granularity
and the text will grow
and shrink to fill
the available text view space.
EditText can now be autofilled.
Much of this will
happen automatically
but you can help the
Autofill provider do a better
job by giving it hints.
You can also mark fields
that Autofill should ignore.
Adaptive icon support in
Oreo allows app developers
to control the way
their icon appears
with launchers and devices
that use different icon
shapes, with an
additional layer that can
be used for animated effects.
Android Studio
includes a new wizard
for creating adaptive icons.
And O has added support
for fractional inset values
to make it easier to use legacy
resources to build these icons.
Android has a new
native audio API,
AAudio, designed for
low latency tasks,
such as effects processing
and real-time synthesis.
It's easier to use and
adds a new direct mode
that if implemented by an
OEM allows to reduce latency.
There's so much to discover in
Android O, which also includes
updates to playback
and recording,
seeking and reversing
animator's sets,
multi-process web
view is Safe Browsing,
StrictMode enhancements,
seekable file descriptors
with media file access, more
language support, and more.
Check out the links to learn
more about Android Oreo
and how we're helping
developers leverage key
features using the
support library.
Also see how we're
improving Android
development with the launch
of [INAUDIBLE] support,
architecture components,
and Android Studio 3.0.